the other great news which you may not  have heard we announced earlier in the  broadcast is my two new co-hosts shel  Miller Dana Jacobson two of my favorite  people it's I have a lot of people I  love it I like these two  as much as anybody better now we have  your back I know you do but I mean that  with all sincerity and I'm so happy you  both are here well you know we've been  absolutely glowing all day since  yesterday since the announcement Billy  giddy yeah yeah I'm just really thrilled  to be here because this is one of the  well one of the best shows on television  now I have to say be best show on TV but  if we do say so ourselves yes we will  well I'm glowing too and welcome to both  you